at the white house there is confusion
this morning after the president said
he would stop talks aimed at helping
americans through this pandemic
and then appeared to reverse course the
president made no public appearances
yesterday as he continues to battle the
coronavirus
but on twitter he did call for his
negotiators to walk away
from efforts to pass a second stimulus
package that message
immediately sent stocks into a nosedive
and drew
sharp criticism from members of both
parties more than 26 million americans
are unemployment right now many are in
desperate need of help
nancy cordes is on capitol hill nancy
the president has since tweeted he does
want some type of stimulus what exactly
is going on here
well his flood of tweets last night
anthony indicates that he
is aware of the fallout over his
decision to walk away but the piecemeal
approach
he's now proposing is unlikely to win
support
from democrats i can tell you from
talking to aides on both sides
that his announcement that he was
pulling out of the talks
came as a surprise to both parties
it all started tuesday afternoon when
the president abruptly tweeted
i have instructed my representatives to
stop negotiating until
after the election when immediately
after i win
we will pass a major stimulus bill that
means that americans at least for now
will not be getting another round of
1200 dollar stimulus checks
just a few hours before the president's
announcement the federal reserve chair
was making the case for more rescue
funding
now too little support would lead to a
weak recovery
creating unnecessary hardship for
households and businesses confusingly
the president tweeted that he
agreed with powell after he had shut
down the talks
his decision sent the dow plunging
almost 600 points
and drew fire from the airlines the
chamber of commerce
and even some republicans amid the
backlash the president took to twitter
again in the evening saying congress
should approve
25 billion in funds for airline workers
and 135 billion for small businesses
as well as those twelve hundred dollar
stimulus checks
speaker pelosi called the president's
move to end the talks
an act of desperation and in a phone
call with fellow democrats she
speculated
that the steroids he is on for covid may
be
impacting his thinking
one person who did agree with the
president's decision was senate majority
leader mitch mcconnell who said that the
two sides were still pretty far apart
and were unlikely
to reach a deal in time for the election
anyway but
other republicans worry that by walking
away the president
is going to get the bulk of the blame
and that that could affect the entire
party
right before election day tony either
way millions of americans do not have
time to wait nancy thank you very much